Xenia wants to participate in a broccoli and carrot cutting competition.
It takes the same number of seconds to cut a carrot or a head of broccoli.
Its purpose is to cut at least 20 vegetables for 540 seconds.
The graph below shows the set of all combinations of carrots and broccoli.
Inequality A presents the set of all the combinations that Xenia wants to cut.
Because she wants to cut at least 20 vegetables.
So, inequality A suggests that she wants to cut at least 20 vegetables.
All this blue colored area,
which is dense, i. the right points are also included.
These are all variations in which she cuts at least 20 vegetables,
all this blue area, including blue rights.
Inequality C presents the set of all combinations,
which she can cut within the specified time.
So, inequality B is all the combinations in which it fits in the set time
and does not use more than 540 seconds.
What is the smallest number of carrots that Ksenia can cut and reach its goal?
She remembered she wanted to cut at least 20 vegetables.
You want to be in the blue zone.
You want to be in the multitude of decisions about inequality A,
which is in the blue area or on the blue straight.
She wants to achieve her goal and meet the time constraint.
But it must also be within the framework of the many decisions
for inequality C, so it also needs to be in
the green area or the green line.
So overlapping both,
when it meets both conditions,
this is the whole area.
This is the overlap
of the two sets of solutions.
In this area of ​​overlap where is the smallest number of carrots?
What is the smallest number of carrots,
which Xenia can cut to achieve its goal?
If we look at here, the smallest number of carrots ...
you may be tempted to say: "20 carrot,
it is in the multitude of decisions. "
It's 20 carrots and zero broccoli heads.
But you can also find a combination,
in which there are even fewer carrots.
You can go right to this point,
because do not forget the points you make
are also included in the plurality of the solution,
because they are dense lines, not interrupted.
So this point here,
10 carrots and 10 broccoli heads,
actually meet its purpose.
So let me write it down.
10 carrot and
10 broccoli heads.
Let me just write it.
So, this is the smallest quantity.
If you want to find less than 10 carrots,
in each of these variations there will be no overlapping.
If you are looking for a way to cut 9 carrots
and look here - at C equal to 9
there is no overlap between the two sets of solutions.
So the minimum quantity here is
the point of intersection of these two straight lines.
10 carrots and 10 broccoli heads
is the combination at which she cuts
the minimum number of carrots,
to achieve both goals:
to be within the time and cut at least 20 vegetables.